Welcome to the Anna National Show. I'm Anna Ashley. We're here at Congress Clinic. We are doing part three of our EMF series and today we're going to talk about the very serious topic of 5G technology and we are doing this episode this part is to bring awareness to this topic.
We by no means are 5G experts. We've just been doing a little bit of our own research and yeah so it's just really to get awareness out there to start the conversations and because it is something that is going to affect our health.
Yeah, so whether we like it or not. Yes. Yes. Most of you probably only know about 5G because of the commercials.
Verizon we're building the most powerful 5G experience for America. That's why the NFL chose Verizon because they need the massive capacity of 5G with all your wide band.
So we're streaming streaming, posting fans and experience 5G all at once. This is happening in 13 stadiums all across the country. Now Verizon 5G can do this for the NFL.
Imagine what it can do for you.
They are more glamorous than it's not telling you the truth obviously. It's going to make it seem like it's something you want and you need and you're excited for.
AT&T is creating the 5G network that will change the world. It will be everything you imagine and everything that hasn't been imagined yet.
How far into the future did you go?
So then you think that's the power of AND. When I saw was on the NFL they were representing 5G and the stadiums and that it's going to be making everything faster for you and their stadium which is again hiding the truth of what it actually is going to do.
It's going to be everywhere and like you're saying they're trying to make us think it's something that we need in our life by being hyper connected at this hyper speed.
I don't know. I don't really know people who are asking to be hyper connected. I kind of feel like we're too connected. You need to do it sometimes and too addicted to all of our devices.
So the idea of super speed being able to download things really quickly. I don't know. I have all of this to access but trying to portray it is something we need in our lives.
It's really something we don't need but they're just going to do it anyways. We don't really have control. They're not asking for opinions or just developing this technology and implementing it.
Yeah across the nation and so it's something that needs to be talked about.
Oh absolutely. And we already know that radiation damage is DNA and the 5G technology is not taken away 3G or 4G.
It's just in addition to what we already have, it's this extra you know this hyper short and wave length frequency that is going to be transmitted super fast obviously but in order to get that everywhere we have to have millions and millions of cell towers and they are going to be small.
So they're going to be able to be placed you know with it you know on your homes on the tops of buildings in the street lights in these devices that you're talking about having in your homes they're all basically going to be little receivers for all of this 5G frequency.
This image was online is describing exactly that so you can see here just bombarded with every type of receptor and every appliance constantly all day every day.
Yeah basically we're going to be human microwave. So I was reading it was saying 5G will be similar to turning on your microwave leading the door open and having it on for the rest of your life and standing in front of it.
So we're basically cooking ourselves here on super scary and the skin thing right and so while 4G technology the wave lengths are just traveling on a surface of your stand 5G we know that is immediately absorbed so it's absorbed by your skin through your sweat glands and so it literally is heating the skin and literally is yeah cooking us.
In microwave eyes and sweat glands are the antennas for that radiation. Yeah and like what are you going to do with your eyes or your sweat glands?
Yeah I know.
We're talking like we need to do this since we've heard it protects ourselves.
Because we already know it's damaging and the scary piece too is that there are no studies on 5G this radiation and the long term effects.
So we are you know it's damaging but we don't know the long term effects so we are a human science experiment and not only us as humans but animals and the plants and the planet the whole living ecosystem is going to be effective.
And they aren't doing research because they don't want to wait they specifically said in some interviews we want it now we don't want to wait we're not going to do a couple of year long study like other countries are doing because we're America we have to do it first and the best and we have a history of doing things without researching it and just putting up with the consequence after and the result of it like the vaping that occurred.
All of those injuries they didn't research long term effects. We're just trying to get a product out there to make money.
Exactly. And now get those injured kids even like at what cost are we doing and we're doing it to ourselves. Like why?
Like you said no one asked for it. Yeah no one is asking for it. It's just something that's being implemented and without consent.
And the like itself on companies who install them too if your city agrees not to have them your state can be sued for taking them down is something I don't quote me on that.
We are messengers of this information don't get mad at us for what we come across but we encourage you to do your own research.
You have to do your own research and you have to start thinking about these things because of the effects and start questioning and we'll link some things to this video and how you can take action.
What you can do reach out to your local officials write letters, voice your opinion, voice your concern, demand for more research, delay, how can we delay this?
We can come together and write the more people that voice their opinions and voice their concern, the more we are heard.
4G can go up to as high as 6 gigahertz and 5G can bring us to 30 to 100 gigahertz range.
Again, we've never been successful to, especially long term.
There's also 5G according to the World Health Organization, they classify radio frequencies at radiation and they put 5G in comparable to a class 1 carcinogen along with arsenic.
It's like why on a toxic scale, why are you doing this?
They're going to be putting the antennas on every single block and it'll be a range between 20 meters from your house.
When you say personal, well, they were saying that it was like every two to eight houses will have the equivalent to their own cell tower for every two to eight houses.
That is mindable.
Like, I don't email a cell tower, thanks.
I'm gonna ask for an item of importance.
I probably don't need my own cell phone.
Exactly.
Again, it's not something that you can plan on testing, they don't look out on term damaging results.
They want to be the first nation and then they will be putting 20,000 satellites to cover the planet.
So again, how are we going to even escape it?
You leave earth.
No, it's just like you can't even go in nature without having 5G on you.
Oh, we didn't cover that, it's a tracking device.
So it can go through the level that it's at because it's a military crane level.
It can actually go right through concrete walls.
So it'll be really easy to get into your home.
It will be obviously on your phone because you want your phone to be faster and better and whatever.
But it'll be able to sit there and track you right then and there.
Which we already have facial recognition in play.
So this is like that on steroids.
Right.
It will be able to link to other cameras that you go to target.
It will link you to target.
It will never be scanned.
Yeah.
It will be tracked from camera to camera to...
Exactly.
It is like the movies.
It literally is totally out of the movies.
And they were saying to like you can be watched when let's say you go target.
Who doesn't go target?
So you go to target and let's say you just browsed whatever you left with nothing.
Right.
So you want you to be a consumer.
So then they can play you.
Next time you go to target.
In bot and up they lipgloss.
We're going to market lipgloss, which they already do.
You know, your Google searches.
Yeah.
All those act just talking about something your phone will pick out.
And your Facebook ad will be whatever you were just talking about.
And it's like, okay.
So now add 5G in the trackable the way that it can.
It's just they want you to be a consumer and have that control over.
Make you think that's what you want.
Yeah.
And it's like control.
It totally is.
Totally.
It's not funny.
No, it's not.
It's terrifying.
What do you do laugh or cry?
I don't know.
But yeah.
It's uncomfortable because it's how do we even...
How does that even seem like a good idea?
Right.
And most people want to need it.
Some people want to disconnect.
Well, how do you disconnect your phone off?
No.
There's a satellite above you.
Yeah.
What?
It's so...
It's scary.
This is a scary topic.
Their goal is to, according to the government, when they had their interviews.
They want to make the nation safer and healthier.
Again, slam rise.
Yeah.
Exactly.
I don't know how that will make me safer because you're watching me.
Are you going to protect me too?
Are you my security system?
Right.
Or how is it going to be healthier?
You are literally exposing us to excess radiation.
We get enough already with what we have.
I just can't wrap my head around their thinking.
Yeah.
To that extent.
The only conclusion you can come to is that it's for ultimate control of the population.
It's scary.
It is scary.
And it will just...
Oh my gosh.
It's just...
I don't want to know.
It's going to be like after a year.
The sicker will get sicker.
Yeah.
And the healthy will get sick.
That's literally...
When you set an open microwave, that is so...
I can't.
Like, how do you not get sick from that?
Yeah.
We will get sick from that.
And then who's going to take care of the sick?
Basically self-destructing.
That is absolutely right.
So, your LED lights.
They will also be putting into your house.
We'll have a little microwave.
Not exactly sure what they called it, but it was some type of...
What do these turn?
It's like a microwave transmitter.
Yeah, in the LED light.
So, again, now you have your devices, but now you have the lights that you use.
And, you know, and the sad thing too is that little kids are more susceptible.
Oh, yeah.
I would imagine that elderly as well, just people who are...
Yeah.
You know, brains developing susceptible to things because they've aged and immune system.
All of these things to protect our bodies are straight into decline.
And, you know, there's going to be...
It's just to behavior issues.
I mean, look at the world that we live in today when all of the mental health issues
and the school shootings and all of these things that are happening
just in, never before seen amounts.
And it's only going to get worse with all of this exposure
and what it's going to do to behavior and to blame health and to moods and overall health.
And it's incredibly scary.
Well, and they set the safety standard so high that they can get rid of that.
And they're trying to say that it's...
That it's considered safe, but then the range...
When the range is outrageous.
So it's...
Okay, so it's measured in microwat centimeter squared.
So, a cell phone was researched to be able to function at 0.000000002.
That is so small.
You know, like, if your cell phone shouldn't...
It should be still functioning just that and we would not be harmed.
So, they're elite.
So children's symptoms can start to occur if they're exposed to 0.05.
Okay, now where does all of this add up?
So, a couple more researched things.
Extreme concern should start when you're exposed to 0.1.
Laptops, Wi-Fi, sperm DNA and decreases sperm and adult symptoms start at 1.0.
So, that's things we're exposed to every day.
And we have already...
Cresories being exposed to these things.
And we're currently seeing racism infertility.
Like we talked about in the school and all those symptoms you just described.
So, that is without 5G.
Then, at 2.5, it showed altered calcium metabolism in the heart muscles.
So, now you're already impacting and forwarding at 2.5.
At 4.0, your hippocampus starts changing and you're affecting your learning and your memory now.
DNA damage occurs at 6.0.
So, your smart meter, just 1 alone, contains 7.93 micro watts per centimeter squared.
Now, you're already damaging your DNA just with 1 smart meter alone.
That is wild because that you don't get a choice on either.
I didn't even know there was one on my house.
I just looked right at you.
Actually, you have to call and tell them after it's already been installed against your wishes.
Yeah.
And have them replace it.
And then you're charged at fee.
And then to come out and do that, it probably another fee on top of it to have the original...
I don't know what it is.
They have a lot of device where they actually have to come out and read the meter and pay that person.
Yeah.
Oh, that is...it's so magical.
And just a smart meter alone.
And so, then after you're exposed to all of this radiation, I guess, or this amount of micro watts,
then your behavior can start to change when it reaches 10.
So, 10 is so pretty low, I guess, because apartments with 12 smart meters reach 19.8.
That is very high in a lot of people in apartments.
So, now you're already exposing them to more than 30 minutes and their behavior could start to change.
30 and these already changing.
Yeah.
In fertility might be on their eyes with this firm DNA.
It's like, crazy.
But the standard for US and Canada, they set the safety to 600 to 1,000 micro watts.
That's like way off the charts.
Monetary of these people who make these safety standards.
So, that's exactly why 5G can expose you to so much because it's considered safe,
even though it's not a reasonable term.
And we know radiation is damaging.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a huge topic.
And obviously there's some huge red flags that we just discussed.
And there are things you can do to protect yourself.
Again, you're never going to be able to get away from it all together.
But in part, one and two of the EMF series we talked about ways that you can kind of protect your home,
ways that you can protect yourself and your kids and specific things that you can do.
So, be sure to go back and reference those.
And again, this conversation is just to bring awareness to things that aren't being discussed and you're not being told.
So, please do your own research, share this video with your loved ones.
You know, get help, get the word out.
Certainly like and subscribe to these videos for more information that pertains to health topics
that people should really be concerned about.
And yeah, we'll attach.
There's also some links through our research that we'll attach to.
So, and then of course, there are communities that put together websites to bring more awareness on injuries they've experienced.
So, we'll also include those two.
It's a big deal.
Yeah, it's a big deal.
And we should be thinking about big things about this and taking action because of smart cities.
That's what they want to create.
Well, stay tuned for our next episode.
Yes, I don't know what the topic is going to be yet, but it's a surprise to all of us.
We'll make sure it's a good one.
Thanks for watching.
Thank you.